what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so the other day we did a video on
imagine Jasper's too powerful for Marvel
movies too powerful for the MCU and I
think I might move that to Sunday which
means now we get to do it today but I
was sitting here thinking I was like if
we do that like which character would we
do next cuz it has to be one who's
recognizable I did Mad Jim Jasper's just
for the sake of being able do imagine
Jasper's but we're like we're also
trying to make sure we reach like a
large audience of people right because
like we're trying to grow the channel so
my thought was like which character
would we do and then it dawned on me
there were two characters that I wanted
to do but this one that I want to do
here I think is cool basically like God
Thor or rune King for now rude King Thor
is crazy powerful for like two pages and
as it will not really even two pages
he's actually powerful for the rest of
the story for Thor disassembled okay so
if those are guys who were new to comics
wind the clock back
did you like 2004 or 2005 right so
Marvel is like okay all these characters
are super ope and everything is really
really powerful and all that kind of
stuff so Marvel does a whole bunch of
different things the first thing they do
is they D power 98% of the mutant
population right like take their powers
away that happens in a story with the
Scarlet Witch called House of M where
she takes away 98% of the mutant
populations power she literally says no
more mutants and they all lose their
abilities now from there
Marlow starts like taking away
characters because they're going into
the events of civil war the problem with
civil war is that it's a fight among the
superhero community but if Thor was
there or if like The Incredible Hulk was
there and then whatever side they were
on would basically win and so in this
instance Marvel says okay we're gonna
write Planet Hulk and we're gonna write
Hulk out of the picture so like Greg Pak
writes that story The Incredible Hulk
ends up on another planet sent there by
the Illuminati and then they turn to
Thor and so what we end up getting is
Thor disassembled we basically get the
events of Thor Ragnarok which is kind of
cool most people know what goes on with
the Thor Ragnarok story it's basically
this idea that like Loki sets in motion
a series of events that ultimately leads
to like an invasion of Asgard now Odin
is dead by this point and so he's just a
disembodied corporeal essence called the
odinforce and he appears to Thor for a
little while but Thor tries his best to
face off you know to defeat the forces
of Loki and he gets absolutely decimated
right he gets like absolutely wrecked
and so what ends up happening is Thor is
is you know he's defeated he's like like
on his last leg he ends up calling in
the help of Captain America and Iron Man
and then the fight is joined by beta ray
bill who's actually the first person to
lift a hammer of Thor video evil fans
you don't find a whole lot of them but
they are fiercely loyal to beta ray bill
it's crazy and like Thor fans love him
too he's a
korbinite he's like the protector of his
people more or less and like they're
making their way to the solar system and
like Nick Fury and shield pick up on
what's going on so they're like Thor go
check that out Thor gets their beta ray
bill beats the hell out of him and then
takes his hammer it's it's crazy but
anyway so with the defeat of Loki coming
from like Vader evil Captain America
Iron Man and Thor from there the
question becomes like how do you like
like how could this have happened and
his Thor's search for knowledge right so
Thor's met with the odinforce those you
guys who don't know the odinforce is
basically just the life energies of Odin
combined with the life energies of his
brothers viele Envy and that's basically
it
it's not as weird it's basically being
able to say like we need a soy we're it
worth the world like Odin can do
something that he can't normally do and
the questions like well how it's like I
don't know own force it's like the Speed
Force from the flash right you know I
ain't got explained so like it's one of
those crazy things when it comes to
Marvel comics and so so with with the
odinforce kind of being like disembodied
it guides Thor on this spiritual journey
and what the odinforce tells him is that
in the early days of Odin's rise to
power he had to sacrifice an eye to the
well of Mamere I think it is in order to
gain like vast amounts of knowledge but
the question is is Thor willing to do
that not only that all four is going to
gain is the knowledge Odin had the same
kind of power Odin had the question is
does Thor want the same knowledge and
power of Odin or does he want more and
so the idea is like Thor wants more he
wants the full totality of everything
that's going on and so what is up
happening is Thor sacrifices both of his
eyes and he essentially gets like twice
as much power as Odin has he wields
what's called the Thor force but it's
basically the odinforce with the Thor
name but like at that point in time he
essentially becomes God like he's on
mission and and like it's insane how
much power he has because imagine Odin
being twice as strong as he normally is
and Odin is powerful as hell I mean
Odin's like liheap with like he put the
hurt on Galactus dude there's this like
amazing seat dude okay it's not J
michael Straczynski Thor it's somebody
else's Thor one I care for what it is in
the first story arc Odin fights off
against fights against Galactus and
Galactus is like dude I'm so tired of
Asgardians like I hate these things like
like Odin like headbutts the hell out of
out of Galactus and I'm pretty sure like
cracks his helmet and like Galactus is
like Asgardians you bore me and like
like dude Odin puts the hurt on it but
he uses so much energy that he has to
like power down and go into the Odin
into the Odin sleep but like he stands
toe-to-toe against Galactus which is
pretty damn impressive ah but still like
imagine Odin being like twice as
powerful like twice that level of power
that he had and his fight against
Galactus and that's where Thor is and
Thor's just like this on this like
insanely powerful omnipotent being and
so what he does is he he gains all this
knowledge and he ends up realizing that
like everything that's been going on
with the events of Ragnarok are a cycle
it's a cyclical pattern in Odin broke
the pattern death by by whatever manner
in whatever means which Marvel teased
the ideas in what was it was in the last
days of Loki during the events leading
up to secret worst model T's the idea
that it was actually to beyonders but
there was this group out there that were
just called the ones who sit above in
shadow and we don't really know anything
about them we didn't really know where
they came from or how they function all
we knew is that whenever as Guardians
saw them they looked like as Guardians
so it's the Galactus principle right
like like in the trial of Reed Richards
model established that Galactus appears
as whatever race lives on the planet
that he's attacking so like if Galactus
shows up to the scroll planet he'll look
like a scroll if he shows up to earth
he'll look human if he shows up on the
Kree homeworld he'll look like a creep
it's just the mirror effect and that's
how the ones who sit above in shadow
work but the way this happened is that
somehow they came into existence and
then eventually Asgard came into
existence and then the first Ragnarok
happened and when it did the ones who
sit above in shadow fed off all the life
energy led off by the Asgardians when
they all died and then all the
Asgardians came back into existence
again Asgard was recreated and they
continued on until Ragnarok happened and
the cycle repeated itself over and over
and over again and this had happened
countless tons it had happened since
like the dawn of the universe or maybe
even before and so when Thor realizes
that he's like okay so we have to
destroy the ones who sit above in shadow
because his idea is in every single
instance of Thor of Asgard's creation
and its lifespan before the events of
you know that telling of the story what
had happened was it for he just lived
his life on Asgard and he has just been
the Thor of traditional Norwegian mythos
but then in turn Odin broke the cycle
and Odin said okay the only way to
really defeat the ones who sit above in
shadow it's to do something different so
that's one of the reasons he cast Thor
down to earth also because he was kind
of a dick when he was younger but like
he cast him down to earth and said
you're gonna go live with the Earthlings
and you're gonna gain a tried-and-true
understanding of what like right and
wrong is good and evil and all that kind
of good stuff and so when when all that
happened he basically became the Thor
that we all know and love and then
return to Asgard and that set in motion
where he is at the time of that story
and so from there he's just kind of like
well we have to destroy the ones who sit
above in shadow and so using his hammer
and using like the full power of the
runes which basically make him God he
smashes the tree of Idris so like
completely shot
the treat like after confronting that
once you said above in shadow and in
doing so destroys them all
and is absolutely insane because if what
Marvel says is true if what Marvel says
is that the ones who sit above in shadow
were the D honors if the events of the
last days of Loki are accurate and the
ones who sit above in shadow were the
beyonders then by virtue of being the
rune King Thor was at least presumably
powerful enough to like frighten the
beyonders and send them running away and
so it's just kind of like that's pretty
damn powerful especially we consider the
power that the beyonders are powerful
enough to like annihilate the Living
Tribunal now I don't think it means that
room King Thor's on par with a living
tribe you know but still like it's a
pretty crazy Display of power and that
would never work in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because what happens when you
have a version of Thor's character who's
basically ruined King you can make that
argument that he's kind of that level
right now but he's not like he's Thor
with like the odinforce so like he's
half as powerful as he would be if he
had like the the full power of the runes
and if he was like rune King Thor but if
he were like full on rune King Thor
where he's like omniscient and like
omnipotent and basically like
indestructible how do you make a movie
with that like who would you have him
fight I guess maybe you could have him
fight Galactus but like you're talking
about a character who's nyeh unstoppable
on like a universal level and so at that
point and it's like who the hell's he
gonna fight you you can't do a story
like that and even if you could you'd be
talking about a level of power between
two beings that's easily enough to
destroy entire planets or solar systems
even potential galaxies possibly even
fracture the fabric of the universe
itself or send shockwaves through it
that would impact things to like an
insane level we imagine that like Thor
goes to smashes hammer on some villain
it knocks them back and like sends
ripples through the universe and when I
say ripples I mean you can see the
fabric of the universe move like like
that that kind of stuff would be crazy I
mean that level of power would be
bonkers in the in the movies and even
the comics just stretches the limits of
credulity because you would think with
someone rising to be that powerful the
Living Tribunal would step in but I
guess it wouldn't because it's not like
there's two versions of Thor who were
ruined King running around out there so
I guess it stands you know it stands to
reason it could it could happen but
still like you can't do a version of
that character in Marvel Cinematic
Universe because he's just too powerful
and you wouldn't really have anybody he
could fight I mean if you guys think fan
O's in the MCU with with that power of
the Infinity Gauntlet is powerful I mean
he is but like imagine
danos with the Infinity Gauntlet in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe fighting rune
King Thor like the power he had in the
comics it'd be no contest because in the
MCU Thanos is a lot weaker with the
Infinity Gauntlet than he is in the
comics and the comics it was insane like
it was
nuts the kind of how her he had it was
crazy stuff like I mean sure he used the
reality stone and he messed up like Drax
a destroyer and then he messed with with
mantis and so on and so forth but like
imagine like during the fight with
Thanos on on Titan or whatever that moon
was built like iron man goes to attack
him and he just turns him into like a
pile of iron man toys like that's the
kind of stuff you saw and the events of
like the Infinity Gauntlet story it was
ridiculous like in the power he
possessed but still like like like rune
King Thor would be absolutely bonkers
like it would be an insane level of
power I would argue he could probably he
could rival King Hyperion from the
universe where King Hyperion destroyed
all the cosmic entities and all the
superheroes like I'd say he could
probably be that powerful but even then
it's not consistent cuz like King
Hyperion destroyed Galactus and like all
the cosmic entities in his own universe
and then gets beat by like blue Marvel
like it doesn't really make any sense I
mean blue whale was cool
Adam Breshears pretty badass and like
he's an absolute Hoss
man blue Marvel do I really want to see
Adam Brashear in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
I wonder who would play him if I Drew's
elbow wasn't playing Heimdall I'd say
make him blue mother he'd be an amazing
Adam er sure he'd be man I'd imagine you
out of Bashir I would love to see that
like damn that have been cool have like
an infinity Hall right like in the
infinity war movie like Thanos is about
to snap his fingers blue Marvel just
like races in takes a Gaul and he's like
you're done and then just leaves and
Thanos is like what and they just flies
back and just beats the hell out of blue
Marvel would would absolutely thrash
Thanos from like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it would it would be it'd be
like child's play but yeah I don't know
I mean I'm anyway we're going off on a
tangent we're going off on and on to
think ruin King Thor you cannot put him
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe just
too damn powerful it's just it's it just
doesn't work just way way too extreme
either that or you would have to nerf
the hell out of you have to make him a
whole lot weaker and that's just not
gonna fly but with that being said guys
were gonna bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comments explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]